okay for those who are on this
livestream this is another in our now
quite long series of software
architecture review meetings that we are
live-streaming
we're actually doing several today I
believe this one is about new features
in image audio and signal processing
going into the upcoming version of
Wolfram language and I suspect this is
going to consist of a large number of
fairly small items but we'll see what
there is ok so let's get started all
right so let's start off with the image
trim so what should I look at the
documentation page yes
how are the ROI specified by the way it
looks like we need sub image as a
spelling word how I'll send that in um
go ahead how are the regions of interest
specified that table that first table
you can specify a list of points a
region and an image or a function so
when we have a machine learning function
that responds with the you know the
bounding box of the elephant in the
image or something what is it giving
back and is it easy to feed that into
image exactly that's a constant region
queue so that qualifies as that second
entry of the table region to your 3d
graphics geometric region so that so
that thing comes back as a rectangle and
then you feed the rectangle into image
trim right can I try that I mean is
there an image is there an image what
would I do image position or something
image position gives you gives you
single points in image bound bounding
boxes you wanna well it was what is
image positions this is the one that
gives that the undocumented function
with image contents which basically
gives the single XY position
representing the object that you've
asked for so if I say let me pull up a
picture um if you do find faces right
which as well has changed down down the
list or okay okay well let's just do um
let's do a web in research for herd of
antelope well that's not to antelope we
might not have antelope elephants how
about that um let's get some thumbnails
of those so what what should happen is I
should be able to find the elephants boy
I don't know how well the limited the
elephants are going to be let's try that
one there um so what do I do I say image
positions of that comma elephant all
right yeah if you want bounding boxes I
would do image bounding boxes of
elephants let's try that so that works
um
do you think this is gonna work I asked
to check if elephants were in their
classes of trained in the yeah well
there you go
something's okay so right right so now
let me let me play with this what do I
do to highlight with that highlight
image the same image and those positions
okay
very cool that's really quite nice okay
so now let's say I want the bounding
boxes of the elephants mm-hmm image
bounding boxes
um and then it's the same jazz with the
elephant's back okay so now you're
saying I can go image trim of that
original elephant picture yes map that
onto those things there yep or in fact
you don't need them map because we now
support multiple regions of images the
regions of interests I see okay cool I'm
going to save this because this is a
nice I like these examples
I go I wanted let's see where do I want
to save this um
oh whatever I'll just save it at the top
level there for now
okay finish processing one we may end up
with some useful examples here okay uh
okay cool
very nice
and that's okay so that's the maskavich
how would I get the masks from here how
would I get the elephant masks so to
speak
Oh what do you mean well I want to get I
want to get it you know pixel value one
in the over the exciting that elephant
what's that for that bounding box I
think you well oh but the elephant
itself that we don't have a function
that gives you back segmentation for the
elephants as far as a neural network
function you can do more image
processing to do region growing for
instance around those positions that you
found seems like we should have a
segmentation function known that based
segmentation function right
that's the next step for image contents
for now our image contents is doing just
bounding boxes are we documenting image
positions in this version mmm no because
we yet don't have the larger training
are you sure what when is that coming I
mean I thought Sebastian was now ready
to do that I'll talk to him again yeah
I'm pretty sure that's coming okay well
that looks nice for image some image
trim okay masking masking is an option
to a bunch of things yes and we're going
to add it to more things but for this
version we are just supporting regions
as well here
so things like rectangles or any yeah
look what isn't referenced here that
should point to masking right yeah could
be nice
should we put it at the end I think so
undoes masking point back to image trim
no and I think even more importantly
maybe we want to link to some
segmentation functions yes
like what binarize region minor eyes
remove background maybe to begin with
even before image apply I think so yes
these are very old see also
what is it cult remove background right
I think you should fix this seal source
let's not do them all here um but I
think also um okay so when I see image
take does image take have does it also
have region of interest specifications
know if this one goes with that takes
intact so it's rows/columns slices
center seems to me that as a courtesy we
might as well support region of interest
as well I mean what do you think it's
then just pointless because he's like
now I don't think that that's it doesn't
seem right because it's less I'm
basically doing the same thing as regent
is a much trim yeah but but also this is
a take you know it's a it's it's that's
a take family yeah fair enough and what
about an image crop is this one is the
one that takes the final desired size of
the image I see so in principle image
crop could take you know elephant
instead of size here
maybe that's crazy I mean I mean that's
perhaps crazy because it you know it's
like which elephant are you talking
about kind of thing and you know it
might pick the wrong elephant in the
room so to speak what I would still
think if you want to add that it should
go into image trim fine let me look at
image trim for a second I think it's uh
you know arguably it's not the right
thing to do an image trim because it's
too ambiguous I mean if you have if you
have multiple objects in an image what
are you gonna do I think it's fine I
think what you've done is fine okay all
right let's move on image acquisition so
that's that's current image or on Linux
how does that relate to the Raspberry Pi
support of current image
you were just yeah I I don't think we
has tested actually I'll look into that
because current image has a has its own
driver on Raspberry Pi yeah I don't
think this will affect that okay okay
image capture function what is that
that's part of the image of current
image that's a new option that we that
you suggest that for 11 to but then we
didn't get to implement it implemented
and not for current image but for image
capture because we have one buffer per
camera and we cannot apply more than one
function to it at the same time
we don't want to create more buffers for
each camera for now at least so wait a
minute so what is this doing so whenever
an image is captured we apply the image
capture function to it and then store it
in the buffer
unlike image preview function that gets
applied to the to the image before it's
just displayed I said yeah they use a
preview function can be showing you in
some weird form right say highlight
faces but you don't want to really put
the highlighted rectangles in the buffer
as well right but then for capture
function you may want to do mirroring
left to right mirroring or resizing or
anything of that sort that you actually
want to apply to the frames before you
save us but why wouldn't you just wrap
that around the UM
just wrap that around the image capture
function Oh because you're doing it in
multiple frames there's no what they
capture function is the function that
has to go in as an option so that we
apply that to the images before storing
preview function could have been just a
wrapper like dynamic of age no I get it
but I don't know why aren't you just
saying if you want to left-right Reverse
why don't you just say image reflect of
image capture because then you can we
may want to use previous frames from the
buffer and I think it's redundant to
have to do it if you do image reflector
of image capture then you're reflecting
after acquisition has happened and the
buffer is saved in the buffer the frame
is saved in the buffer but why does it
make any difference whether when it when
you do the transformation as I said we
also have this syntax of care and image
that you can go back in the buffer and
get the last 50 frames and do something
oh I see I see I get it but so then but
how does it work with image with current
image then but current image doesn't
have this option not the capture
function because we don't want different
calls to carry an image with two
different image capture functions okay
so what you do is you do image capture
and then you use current image to go and
fetch previous images and from the
buffer exactly but also something we're
deciding we are planning to do is for
that for each individual camera device
we are adding an image capture function
property which can be set to any
arbitrary function okay that's nice
better than the image capture raft I
mean this all strikes me as a little bit
hokey and you know probably when we are
doing more stuff with video we may yet
regret all these things what do you
think I mean I don't know
you know for example is image capture
function one could imagine woman steal
my video that one might want to do
framed ifs and stuff like that right
there and I doubt this can do that one
argument okay multiple argument forms
let me make this function experimental
can we tag this environmental this is an
option sure let's do it I'll put it in
just to remind us okay all right let's
keep going multiple image capture
capabilities okay that's cool
is that true on all operating systems
yes nice okay image graphics I'm sorry
I'm just moving along because we've got
a lot to cover
um image graphics nothing in the ref
page yet but two things that are coming
one is character polygons if you scroll
down most of the polygons for creating
used to be jagged like that okay so for
example if I look at the sky caramel yet
you'll still get the old result okay but
what you're telling me is it's going to
turn it into Bezier curves or something
or whatever
that's rather disappointing there um now
is there an option to determine whether
it Bezier thighs it
I suppose sorry I didn't think about
that I I think so that that couldn't
spell just be yet another method setting
possibly I mean I don't I don't know
what but but let me ask you this
question I mean sometimes there are
purposes for which you really want lines
because you're trying to use the thing
for some kind of analysis that requires
lines and sometimes you want the most
faithful representation right right
that's why we have currently method goes
to exact to be that close as possible to
that in fact the exact representation of
the regions although maybe we should
have a performance goal here mmm-hmm
maybe we should have a performance goal
which could either be you know simple
simple output
so I think that you know the long-term
evolution of this function I think we
need you know the the stuff there that
there should be an argument or sort of
eventually objectives what's the goal
yeah okay I think we're little distance
away from that right now but I think
that that's where this function needs to
go that you cannot simple high level
objectives yeah but okay so so rather
than a performance goal just stick the
objective right in there as a second
argument right but but as I said we are
a little distance away from that now and
I think an important use case right now
is to get curves correctly right you
know and that you can imagine things you
know they could be things to where you
actually want curves for some processing
purposes but it could also be that you
want just a plot you know scan plot that
you know but what's the curve and we're
getting close to that but again still
nothing index Cara Nobles
maybe we'll get a version of it in 11 3
but most probably we're gonna cook it
well for 12 okay um
question for here's a question when I
want to get the data from a font we have
some wacky way of getting that by
exporting an importing PostScript right
we were going to have a glyph graphics
thing weren't we or some kind of
whatever happened to that lets glyph
graphics it's the thing okay so for
example and who did you talk to about
that I think John faults but I mean I
think that's best bill but but he
shouldn't be the one doing it um I mean
I can go find what this is an amazing
number of error messages class they're
cluster classify Wow okay in any case
the the glyph thing let me let me show
you what I what I remember about this um
I don't even remember let's see cliff
let me just see what I can there is a
extract outline curves from a glyph what
is that
blue work
how's that work well that
looking for was something where you are
extracting things let me see did we have
an example here what's that
no where is the example there is an
example but it's really kind of wacky um
let's see I think it's in the PostScript
right
I may be misremembering where it is it I
found it recently basically the scheme
is you do I mean there is an import that
you can do and get this day you know
because they can be exactly represented
as I know as buffer zone yeah right but
there's there's a way of doing it but
it's really hokey and I think we should
have a way of doing it that isn't hokey
and it's very similar to this function
instead of image graphics it's more like
you know glyph graphics or something
right that will do it's it's more like a
pure import right or you know I'm
imagining what I'm imagining is that you
simply say you know here's a piece of
typeset text write a scene so you know x
squared plus y squared and what I want
from this is the glyph graphics of this
so that does need to be done by
different and team though well it's
already done
I mean it's really just a packaging
problem because there already is a way
to do this well I think okay do we do we
have anybody from project management in
this meeting no is that true that let's
some all right let me let me send
something about this yeah um or I could
make a note to somewhere else about it
should I do that I mean do you really
think it's not for your team yeah I mean
I think the packaging is for you guys
Packaging comes with a whole lot of
problems even as well down the list of
features we have implemented for 11:3 I
have one complaint at least but you you
get something that youth you know you
you send us something that you think
just needs packaging but then it needs
digging and reimplemented and making it
efficient and making it work for all
cases yeah yeah yeah all right
okay the will will look Adam Matt okay
all right I'm putting put making it out
of this um okay
all right let's move on
so so for this version what are you
doing here our support occurs with an
optional what okay and it's too early I
maybe we shouldn't have brought it up we
need to be able to play with it you know
before week okay alright estimated image
depth that that's really cool right
right we we couldn't find we couldn't
they didn't have time to train it
ourselves we have the network in that
model oh do we want to wrap it into a
function for 11:3 I I think if we unless
we've got good training I wouldn't do it
unless it's reliable I mean can we make
it reliable now or is it what is the
function I'm what is the net model can
give you the function you probably don't
have it in there was it in the
repository so can I find it here what is
it up relative depth further down this
is getting this is getting so big in the
last section regression on the
regression second look what an earth is
why is it called run look at these in
details well that seems like the wrong
place for it
doesn't it Begley can we can you tell
Megan Zak where should it be should be
on a british processing on miscellaneous
or what i have to see
sections that are okay well that wasn't
very useful what what is it rather than
an image and probably you need to image
adjust to see the full range of pixels
okay elephants in the fog I mean it
seems to think that the elephants
I don't know stand it
well the tusks seem to be it thinks the
tusks are closer what can I do with this
- actually can I do a relief plot or
something against the how would I do
this how would I see what's good I'm
scrolled down in their net net
repository page there should be an
example that puts it in a less player
one okay
okay cool well let me not do it okay so
so do we think I mean the other question
is estimated image depth so what if we
guess it in this form
I mean what are people gonna want to do
with that I think it's gonna be
useful and remove background eventually
so you can basically separate also but
people are gonna want to do it to try
and we can start 3d geometry single
image there well that's very common
mostly from either stereo yeah I
understand but but you might be able to
do something from this
could we you know what could we do to
support that can we turned into a you
know what things week I mean clearly
there are some we should be able to
infer sides of the regions as well right
size of the region
Salida the side I mean you know what it
would look like from the side as well as
maybe not all right look anyway it seems
like we're not quite ready to have that
maybe for you know for the next version
great we can I like to be able to Train
it as well ourselves that data said used
for this network is fairly limited on
scenes okay alright let's let's go to
find faces okay so do I need what do I
have a suppliant training I mean some
some test data for that okay so what has
happened to find faces syntax wise it's
being we're adding that property and
criteria property could be things like
aerial bounding box position and things
like that and then criteria you can stay
hash age greater than fifty and then we
use facial features well okay
um okay so this is bounding box sub
image
area what is the area like 22
centimeters of square Oh what what do
you mean by ever know that pixel counts
and for now we are returning that pixel
and of the bounding box basically the
area of the bounding box but I think
down the road if we have models that
return ellipses or even completely
segmented regions we can basically be
more accurate about okay so do we have
examples here so I take that example and
I just do default find faces okay so now
if I say image trim of that image with
that yep oops that doesn't like that
does it not support the multi reform yet
yeah it's not supporting the multi form
yet um okay that's that's really nice
okay so now so you also have facial
features
take a look a little bit more in fine
phases so what else we
so these all seem reasonable any feature
and facial features okay so that's a
named feature exactly list of properties
okay faces that satisfy F okay
okay by the way if I say here highlight
image of this thing , percent 11 yeah
very good very nice okay
there is one backwards incompatible
change if you go back to fine faces you
used to have the min/max I saw that yeah
okay for the second argument which was
basically parameters that we pass
through the library to detect faces in
that range now we are making that
parameters for a method sub-option and
then we are making that min Max's syntax
as a post processing so we find all the
faces then we select this somewhere yeah
okay when you're having that little
third argument the criterion argument
exactly can you detach the right now you
obviously support and supported in the
second argument because it's not
conflicting with the properties all
right do you want to generate a warning
so those that that case when generate a
warning for that case um just say it
should go in the other criterion in the
third argument okay so let's do facial
features okay all new all right so if I
just take if I simply take those faces
and I just say facial features of
percent thirteen
something is it going to give an
association for each face here yes
actually a list of associations last
time we discussed it and the machine
learning meeting we decided that facial
feature accepts the original image so if
you even pass it that I said right each
one of these will be an individual face
yes why is this hanging that's not a
good sign shall I bought this I would
say so let's so let's try facial
features just of the original image
again humph
okay we crashed here so something is
wrong do you want to show me facial
features there are examples in the ref
age okay let's say
characters laughs something's gone
can I take a screenshot just hold on
yeah good well I also switched off yeah
who knows what's happened here okay
their racial features what's that the
reflected version of the images we are I
don't know I'll look into it that is
really weird yeah okay facial features
now oh it's producing a data set so by
default we picked the three the three
properties that we thought are commonly
wanted age and their emotion and we're
not giving details of landmarks nose
eyes and so forth is that a good default
you think I think it's okay I think the
age is absurd
I mean I just think that's
embarrassingly over precise okay we'll
make integer I would make it an integer
yes I mean I unless for what is the baby
case looking like I mean in other words
can we detect three-month-old versus a
nine month old baby
well spoiling it yeah well the network
gives us back a distribution okay so
what are we doing well maximum
likelihood seems to be a good good thing
to return for age fine look I think what
we should do why don't you try and be
sensible here and figure out you know
how to round these ages to probably 0.5
or something but I don't know what you
want to do for the baby case okay um but
but that's just looks stupid yeah I
agree
um now presumably can we return the age
distribution from here the inferred age
distribution because that might also be
useful those are some people you have
the age distribution as a weighted data
object what does that mean
what watch what we could do also a
distribution but then we have to
estimate it comes back as a discrete
list of it is actually a weighted data
so for every age we have a weight so if
we want to
an actual distribution we have to
estimate a distribution and we don't
know what's the shape of it I think they
either do you have any comments on this
I mean if you you can you can perform
any descriptive statistic if you want
the median from that it's well defined
or than the weighted data object yeah
but well then why don't we call that
thing age weights age weights okay and
then weigh that data and then return the
weight of data object and if you want to
get some you know statistics from it
then you can just do it okay and why
don't we explore the possibility of an
age distribution if we don't think I
mean it may just be silly because it may
be too much you know maybe like getting
this absurd of a precision thing okay
and I think that's probably the same
thing for expression distribution or we
are now going to call it you know we're
just gonna call it emotion weight
correlation emotion weights gender
weights okay sounds good to me
I'm going to do examples where you
actually use that to call some of those
things like what do mean median or yes
you know or variance which i think would
be interesting to ya or standard
deviation which is sort of in the same
scale yeah right yes times a VI should
be better okay um so now when you give
the left eyebrow so in this case these
noses wherever they were why on earth
are you making a non-default why do you
why do you bother to make that a
non-default highlight image maybe that
was read and not so visible
pick a different facial feature I can't
believe that red noses aren't visible
that should then be a first example
anyways sorry I haven't reviewed all of
them here fair enough um and I don't cry
understand so a nose consists of
multiple lines
what are those nose lines so it has a
bass line on there I don't know what
it's called right there I don't know
what it's called I got the okay two
lines for each of the face for each of
the faces we got one line object but
each one of them is basically two subs
so I mean one ultimate really cool thing
that we could do which kind of leads
into a different one is aligning this
with anatomical data so in other words I
mean this this is in the super hard
category and not seriously suggesting it
right now but um you know an Ulta but we
would love to be able to do right is to
be able to take our anatomical data with
bones and so on and be able to take a 3d
you know a DICOM you know 3d cat scan
type thing and you know conform the
bones that we have an anatomical data
with what you actually see on a CT scan
and similarly here it would be super
cool to be able to take our detailed
anatomical data on a face and somehow
map that onto what is deduced from these
facial feature from the facial feature
detector yeah um but I mean that makes
me wonder what what what is in the nose
so to speak I mean you know okay so it
knows is two lines
what's an eyebrow is an eyebrow one line
is an eye a few point maybe in this
model I think it's the one line but we
could have basically a contour around it
okay but let's let's talk for a second
about what the landmarks actually return
because what you have here you know that
landmark for some reason the nose is
returning a line okay so the nose is not
a line but I don't think we have full
control around that there are different
models being proposed and I'm more
interested in discussing how can we make
this future proof so that if we want to
change from one network to another
general design is still extendable right
but I understand so what we want to
describe then is that the nose is going
to give a geometric approximation
essentially instead of saying you know
if we just a matter of use cases I mean
so one thing is to get sort of a high
fidelity you know geometric
approximation one is to know the
essential features of it sure
like like for example if we want to do
you know face recognition we're going to
need to know I mean there there are
certain set of parameters that you need
and where are the parameters that you
need for biometric type stuff which I
think are various distances and so on
right there's a standard set I believe
shaadi sorry took me to me a few seconds
to find on mute so I'm asking when we
look at biometrics to a face right I
mean it will be nice to have something
where you're just returning essentially
the you know the Engram the biometric
Engram of a face yeah which you probably
can deduce from you know distances
between different things and so on
exactly and I think also there's a
coordinate system question right of what
you know relative to the face outline
what is the relative distance of you
know where are the eyes relative to the
outline of the face etcetera etcetera
etcetera ah there must be tons and tons
and tons of literature on this yeah um
it seems uh knob vyas to me I mean what
we're doing here is obviously an
interesting start but I think you know
the facial landmarks what we want to say
is we're going to return a geometric
approximation to each one mm-hmm
if that's what we're doing at this I
think we should release this
experimental I agree that there are so
many unknowns for slice okay but the two
things that seem to me pretty obvious
are you know having something where you
can essentially make a cartoon of the
face right you know transform the face
into a smiley type thing um which you
obviously should be able to do but
these I mean what's interesting here is
just by putting in the list of these
parameters you should be able to feed
them basically directly to a smiley
generator and it should make something
that makes a smiler that looks like you
know that that mirrors that face yep so
we've got that and we've got kind of the
[Music]
you know the the I mean that seems
relevant to Killa when we're looking at
video type stuff and being able to trace
you know the evolution of emotion
through a bunch of frames etcetera
etcetera etcetera
um I mean the other thing there's
obviously relevant to the biometric
application um and we should figure out
how that works
pace morphing as well how are we going
to go from a smile to a frown or you
know from face one you know person one
to person two things like that alright
but anyway I think for right now what
you're doing is you're returning a
geometric approximation to these things
and the quality of that geometric
approximation may later be determined by
some performance goal type thing now all
of these things are in pixels right yes
are we getting ourselves in trouble by
saying estimated gender here in modern
times probably not that's probably as
close as we're gonna get to something
that's okay um okay all right looks
great
all right let's keep going text
recognize next up I actually this is
this is really cool this facial stuff
does it does it work for non-human faces
as long as face detection yeah well as
long as well face detection should
succeed for for anything that is
non-human so first of first off you have
to find the face you know once you
detect there is a face in the picture or
you say this bounding box is a face all
of those you get an estimate for them
fair enough we'll see what it thinks the
eyebrows of the elephant are yes um okay
let's continue texts recognize we're
getting a network for detecting
locations of the text and we are still
using tesseract for recognition but we
are going to send the mask to tesseract
which is going to improve the
recognition we still other not networks
I mean even that Tara's not a school
trained a network on for Chinese and
things that was pretty good we were in
we were in contact with him continued
with him for a month or so after summer
school we are going to have our own
train network for text recognition but
not this version there were there are
some framework limitations or importing
some models into it into my okay but so
so what's happening in and 11.3 is there
what is this in this that's still not
happening the only the only thing that's
happening an actual change is that
masking goes to all is going to change
to masking goes to automatic by default
yes
and so we are going to find the text
first ourselves okay okay
and do we have this fine text function
yet I I started there is actually a page
for it in CVS but as I was drafting it I
realized it's gonna be very similar to
texts recognized and Tech's recognized
already has this bounding box property
so I exclude it excise this for now
we're just going with types recognize
the limit okay so can you request the
text bounding box and text tracking
noise yes all right all right let's move
on um okay Audio audio capture ilanics
great how is the great change of the
audio thing it's the back end we
released all your streaming 11:2 so the
back end of the audio GUI is going to be
all your stream now a lot less code
integrated so if I say audio capture
right now oh okay what is this driver
what an earth is that hello hello hello
hello failed to open device closed
failed to open yeah I don't seem that
I'll look into well it did record
something okay there's no visible change
that I can see in this in the snow
should be more stable okay that's good
we had problems with playing back very
short audio objects or some glitches and
audio capturing some clicking sounds
came back all of those truth because so
if I wanted to do an eight-hour
recording would I be I think so it
starts writing into the file okay
okay audiorecord that's a new function
in the audio stream family so it's in a
sense programmatic capture returns and
audio streams object so what is the idea
here examples yet so wait a minute so
what is this so this is something where
you're opening an audio stream and then
you say on that stream record I'm
confused here
yeah maybe start from audio stream can
you open the page for all your stream
there is a new syntax the second one in
the blue box all your stream of an input
device gives us a handle for an audio
stream I would call that oh I see this
one here that's fine
okay so what what are my audio devices
could I look up my audio devices audio
input devices there okay not our fault
that those things have stupid spaces in
them this is what comes back from your
Mac OS okay um okay so then what here so
on your stream of one of those devices
is gonna give you a handle for a
recording or input stream so let's say I
take first of that let this play audio
that's I've got to display audio I've
got two monitors so what what does that
mean how do i distinguish those two
display audios yeah this is I don't know
we can look into this if you want to go
to your Mac settings your preferences to
see how this is exactly I think how
operating system shows them yeah but we
know because we know if you go here
right let me show you something I mean
if I go no I don't mean that I mean
system apples yeah no no I mean our own
system information right so here if I
look at devices right there they are
I mean okay those are the I admit that I
don't really see the audio devices
connected to these right maybe we should
add them there as well probably should
but if we do add them okay so graphics
subsystem blah
that's very unclear what that means
right because because being able to I
mean it knows there's a screen one on a
screen - but how that's connected to the
audio devices I don't know I mean it's
kind of cool because I could record in
stereo probably from my two monitors if
I want it - mm-hmm but okay but so
you're saying audio stream of percent
for will is that right yeah go ahead
okay so it says stopped so now if I want
to do audio record for some period of
time presumably right no you can stop it
or pause it you can it's a one argument
yeah maybe it should have a direction
something is happening with the voices
here okay but but but in what sense I
mean I don't understand how you use it
without a duration so you basically it's
like audio play and the rest of this
subsystem you know when when you had and
you you had an actual audio and you said
all your stream of the audio you say
audio play that all your object or the
audio stream and then at some point an
event could trigger and all your pause
or all your stuff or you could you could
just call all your stuff and this all
your play is asynchronously playing is
that correct
yes I see and it comes back with a
handle well this is the handle that is
the handle yeah I see so it's like an
external what's a good analogy to this I
mean is it like come it's like a you
know one of our tasks a task object
which is externally just doing its thing
exactly is it in fact implemented using
tasks objects
um I don't know well is it yes it is
should we actually be able to use tasks
I mean like for example how do you kill
the the thing are you stopping the audio
or can you actually kill it and remove
that task you should stop it it's it's
not a task object that you can then do
you mean using the task sub framework
yeah I mean I'm suggesting maybe as a I
don't know whether it's necessary but
being able to call the task functions
directly on these audio streams I think
we looked at it 11 - it would have been
problematic these are all some reasons
why this sub system is still
experimental even I think you were
confused a little bit with the input
streams and output streams I think it's
kind of neat if we can merge them all on
their audio stream but I still don't
know if we can keep them very clear what
each one of them did that is very
confusing I agree because obviously what
you do I mean I see so audio stream
could be an input audio or an output
audio right stream right and but there's
no sense in which it's ever going to be
both is that a true statement you can't
still do things like audio play of a
stream that is being recorded you have
to be yeah you have to be sure it's not
they're not both going through the
built-in stuff so that the echo eyes is
happening but in a sense the idea is
that and all your stream could be you
know populated from an audio object a
file or or an input device and then you
know this is just the beginning of all
real-time stuff for audio okay so look
in the case of audio record yep which
will be read as audio record but so it
goes you you don't in fact have a time
specifier here audio play I think has
max duration doesn't it so maybe this
one sure this part well I mean audio
play it presumably knows the stream may
have an end
yep my situation is there but but you
could you could still turn on the
looping right and then have max nice to
ratios I mean things like device read
time series okay which seemed to me like
there varies that the very similar to
audio record clearly has a time in it
yep um I don't understand how this could
not have a time I mean is it bringing up
a GUI is that the way that you're
supposed to control it it's just
changing their state of the stream which
then you can pause it with audio pause
or stop it with all your stuff I see so
it's starting and how do I get the data
from the recording from the audio stream
audio of all your stream the last note
before the future eyes note mm-hmm I'm
not leaving this very well I mean the
other way around we were doing audio
stream of audio object to get the handle
I think all you over all your stream
which puts all the data into an audio
object is not completely nonsense yeah
but okay but look audio record doesn't
seem like I mean it's it's more like
audio start recording yes and that's
probably a better name I mean in in the
other one and the other one is audio
start playing I would think at the same
time if either one of them is paused you
can restart recording or playing with
the same function hmm
well I just think audio record would
what I would expect is that this is a
blocking synchronous function that you
give it a time and it records for that
period of time that's all your capture
now now if yeah the names might be not
so intuitive but that's that's all you
capture it is blocking its gui-based
okay can it be done but it can be done
capture for a certain amount of time
right yes okay we just fell I think you
didn't like the design we had in there I
know we let's take a look at that
touch the design there yet it smacks to
raesha yeah I mean it'd be nice to me oh
just give a time there although that's
sort of inconsistent with audio capture
to file as one argument hmm okay I'm not
getting this terribly I mean that is
audio record if you don't mind us having
this experimentally released I think
it's gonna help us cook the idea and as
I said this is fine so long as we make
sure to come back to it in the next
version yeah an audio capture I noticed
still also tagged as experimental
exactly okay even though it's been a
while how's it only been eleven point
one yeah yeah Wow that was the first
time we had real-time audio capture well
okay yeah well eleven we released all
you yeah right when we didn't have we
didn't have capture okay fair enough
new option for audio okay audio loop
what wait wait a minute
isn't there a looping option in
animation as well and what is that
looping option called animation
repetitions
that's a yucky name and what what do you
expect in the audio loop case are you is
there a count like that maybe it will be
nice to be able to merge those options I
was also thinking we can extend audio
loop to take a time quantity so that we
say loop until that time but it's it's
kind of we don't a number of times or a
certain number of times yes certain
number of times wouldn't I mean that is
what we get here I think it is you know
part of what we want to do Stephen is
that you know I don't mind us
introducing some of these as
experimental in fact I think it would be
a good thing to do because once we get a
little bit farther along until on the
real time stuff our our universe will
expand yeah jerem saying and we gonna
over a bunch of decisions well okay look
I want to make the point I think
animation repetitions an audio loop have
to be merged somehow animation
repetitions is a decade-old it's you
know that whole mechanism is quite
rickety in my view um I mean audio loop
just as an option I just doesn't make
sense I mean is it audio looping or you
know audio loop sounds like an
imperative verb I
Audio looped looped edy audio but then
if we want to extend it to take a number
or a duration although as I said the
duration or a number is redundant with
our max duration no I understand
look audio looping seems a little less
loopy so to speak
okay this okay um okay all right audio
channel assignment what is that that
tells you you know when you have
multiple channels yes you have a 6
channel audio but only a stereo speaker
how do you want to play this was a this
was already introduced 11 2 and now we
are adding it to all your stream and all
your play this is a minor update it is
important and you you will feel
eventually that it's important
particular will come to music okay um
all right we are out of time here but
let's just take a quick look forward at
what else there is here I think we're
going to have to schedule one more of
these um
satting here okay inverse spectrogram
array did we manage to figure out the
scales for inverse spectrograms if we
want to do that we basically need some
kind of a spectrogram arrange wrapper
your onion
well how goofy does it get I mean so if
I do an audio capture here let's just
say I do an audio capture hello there
okay so now I make a spectrogram oops
spectrogram array well let's just make
let's do a spectrogram array of this why
is it taking forever it's displaying the
largeness okay so if I were to do how do
I do
how do I visualize this you have to
transpose and things like that but very
quickly doing the Ray plot or matrix
plot of apps of that okay is that the
loop around of the Fourier spectrum okay
so if I get that whole suppose this is a
mess isn't it I mean if I'm going to say
this is really not a super usable I mean
the silver spectrogram thing we we are
going to need a different way to do this
what nerve is that and yeah because we
because we don't have the sample rate
and things like that preserve the only
reasonable way to get back the audio is
that the explicitly wrap the data in all
the UN specifies samples right um yep
this
isn't great we should discuss this some
more okay let's do that next meeting cuz
shot isn't my conclusion is that we got
to preserve some of these out of
properties if you want full risk
reconstruct ability yeah well I mean
it's a bit like time series right I mean
in time series you preserve a lot of
stuff I mean this is I would say so that
we have the vey blood data that stores
everything in it what object was this
originally was it was it an array was it
an audio and an image yeah well what
you're suggesting is that what we need
for the spectrogram thing you know audio
is a time domain audio object you're
saying there should be a frequency
domain nobody audio object of some kind
it is it's a short term Fourier
transform right I know that's what the
spectrogram is but the spectrogram is
just a bunch of graphics well I mean if
you want the picture it's the picture
but if you want the data it could be an
object
yeah scientists are trying to preserve
and then and we can have fold you know
then everything is you know is saved
could be some kind of variant of audio
as in something like you know I don't
know what you would call it I'm it's
basically frequency domain audio
representation frequency domain
representation of the audio that's an
interesting idea it's a way of saying
saying that objects yeah right but I
mean then then what we would do I mean
short term Fourier transform is more
general than audio clearly it is yes it
is and maybe that's a mistake to
actually tag it with audio because we
might want to use it for a bunch of
other things why we rename this to be
more Janet generic all right but I mean
so what it suffers some usability issues
you know so well if we had look its if
we had an actual spectrogram wrapper of
some kind then that spectrogram wrapper
could be fed to audio which will then do
the inverse Fourier transform and just
basically do this inverse spectrogram
array right um okay all right let's just
go ahead just because I'm impatient and
well I'd like to is this this is
speechless exercise completely new or
did we have some version of that before
that's a person we had a generic one
which is the same library nor platforms
and now the native synthesizers speech
synthesizers are improving it will
continue to improve because voices you
know gradually more important yep this
can call into those native ones okay we
should look at these some some more by
the way I noticed with XLS I'm gonna
make this point of the a bunch of
character encoding issues on some some
Excel import I did recently I don't know
if we think we've solved that hopefully
if you send us examples we'll look into
it complicated messy example but I do
you think you understand I just want to
make the point somebody should just look
at whether Excel comes with some
indication of character some
standardized character encoding some
indication of it or whether we have to
basically use a heuristic to decide what
the character encoding is likely to have
been I'll look at that Shawn is working
enough on it in details I'll talk to him
about it sounds good
all right to be continued and for those
who were on this live stream that's the
end of this meeting and we're about to
go into a different meeting so talk okay
so see you guys I'll push these
documentation changes thank you okay see
ya